je suis toujours un cap pour les enfants
j'en démords pas c'est pas un jeu en
fait on peut pas jouer avec la santé
mentale des enfants quand ils sont si
jeunes on peut pas savoir ce qui va se
passer dans cinq ans dans 10 ans on peut
pas s'amuser à cacher des trucs sur le
canapé faire des trucs pour gratter 30
balles avec des chaussettes sales papa
moi j'ai envie de dire à Monsieur au
lieu de au lieu de me traiter de cochon
ou de pigeon sur les réseaux reprends ta
famille en main reprends-toi joue le
rôle du père joue le rôle de l'homme et
ne met pas tes enfants en difficulté
comme ça autant si elle a envie de faire
ça et qu'elle a envie de t'appeler de
tous les noms qu'elle a envie de te
griffer ok laisse-la dans son délire
mets-toi reprends-toi j'ai envie de te
demander de te reprendre parce que tu
peux pas laisser tes enfants dans une
difficulté comme ça
ils vont vous répondre
reportage donc moi j'ai bien précisé
vous avez dit beaucoup de choses qui
adressé à moi
t'inquiète pas
pourquoi tu me laisses pas parler
je vous parle après
Amandine alors déjà par rapport au
reportage je pense qu'il faut recadrer
certaines choses je l'avais précisé à
ton rédacteur hier il m'a dit non on le
dira pas ce genre tu le diras demain
donc le reportage qui a été tourné
effectivement il y a beaucoup de scènes
très illustratives notamment les petits
accessoires dans le coffre du
convertible qui ne sont pas un tiroir
simplement tiré on est bien d'accord
c'est un convertible qui est verrouillé
que les enfants ne savent absolument pas
ouvrir d'une part d'autre part nos
accessoires ne sont pas rangés là du
tout d'habitude ils sont dans un sac en
hauteur dans nos étagères dans notre
chambre on a tourné ce reportage sur une
faible amplitude amplitude horaire en
fait en journée quand les enfants
étaient à l'école nos contenus nous nous
les tournons le soir quand les enfants
sont couchés avec une porte verrouillée
et en fait pour que ce soit
représentatif illustratif et comme
Jeremstar avant tout et mon ami on a
toujours un petit peu nous cette façon
d'avoir du deuxième degré et de la
déconnade dans nos tournages là les
accessoires ont été placés à cet endroit
là excessivement pour donner une
illustration à la situation tout comme
la fameuse séquence ou soit disant
continue on ne l'a absolument pas
d'ailleurs prévala plus c'est toi qui
est là je crois dans ton téléphone c'est
Alex qu'il a dans son portable on a la
vraie séquence parce qu'en fait quand on
dit Alex
jeremme filmounou nanana on a la vraie
séquence en fait où jeremme du film on
voit qu'on a absolument pas nul c'est
juste pour illustrer ce qu'on tourne
comme contenu encore une fois le soir
quand on est seul dans une grotte au
quatrième sous-sol il voulait voir ils
vont les voir tes vidéos
parce que c'est vrai en même temps
fait plaisir hier soir mais non je me
fais pas plaisir je suis triste de quoi
tu as juste la rage toute façon tu aimes
personne comme Guillaume Guillaume fait
rigoler tu es bien content moi doute que
je fasse des Story sur son émission de
radio qui sortait au mois de septembre
gratuitement combien je te payer bah non
bah quand même les stories quoi je m'en
fous il était bien content que je fasse
la promotion de son échange
il me donne la puritaine la
bien-pensante c'est pareil alors vous
parlez que mes gosses tu as passé dans
la cour d'école je vais vous poser un
contre-exemple tout simple tout simple
le porno ok c'est accessible au plus de
18 ans le football c'est quelque chose
qui concerne tous les gamins mon fils de
5 ans il aime le foot il va en faire
d'ailleurs ok donc dans la cour d'école
si vous cherchez Marie votre chéri pour
va avoir des propos voiture des propos
comme c'est déjà arrivé très controversé
ou très critiqué par rapport à tel ou
telle équipe ou telle personne puis dans
la cour de récré on va dire ouais Ton
père il a dit ça sur telle équipe machin
moi je suis pour attelle je lui en mets
une alors par contre c'est des gamins de
6 ou 7 ans ont accès au porno il y a un
vrai problème alors soit il y a un
problème d'éducation dans le cas où les
parents parlent de porno devant les
enfants ce qui n'est pas admissible ni
acceptable parce que je vois pas à
quelle heure un gamin de 6 ou 7 ans a
accès au porno pour m'expliquer et s'il
a accès au porno par le biais d'un
tournoi
maintenant
elle nous apostrophe alors d'abord
je finis j'ai pas fini avec Madame si on
a accès au porno en dessous de 18 ans ce
n'est pas normal non plus en fait
personne n'a accès Internet personne
donc dans la cour de récré c'est bizarre
nos gamins ne leur on va pas le faire
les courses
dans la main le soir mais de quoi tu
parles Barbie tu as des enfants s'il te
plaît tu as des enfants
[Applaudissements]
pourquoi
vous avez le droit de mort sur nos
gamins là
mais ça va pas nous nous non non c'est
honteux
on vous voit je l'ai dit à l'antenne
avec une chance vous n'avez qu'une
chance c'est que c'est qu'on était pas
là
c'est la finition
tout le monde va arrêter tu sais même
pas de quoi tu parles on est toujours
les mêmes parents qu'on était il y a
calme-toi ma chérie
vous êtes choqué que les gens soient
choqués mais oublie pas qu'on va mettre
les gens d'honneur
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour 29,99 € sur une plateforme vous la
filmez sur le canapé familial qui est le
canapé aux enfants mange des Miel Pops
le matin en plus
vous filmez ça en plus et en plus vous
venez prendre
une espèce de caution qui vous donnerait
le droit de tourner n'importe quelle
vidéo dégueulasse mais bien sûr que ça
nous choque il croyez pas et moi j'ai
une autre question à vous poser vos
autres enfants ils en pensent quoi ceux
qui ont 10 ans
et je pense malheureusement pour vous et
je ne vous le souhaite pas mais que les
conséquences grammatiques je donne un
conseil l'argent que vous gagnez
mettez-le de côté parce que ça va coûter
cher en psychi
Géraldine qu'est-ce-que
simplement je suis très très gênée je
suis désolé pour toi Léo j'ai
l'impression que vous êtes des bêtes de
foire franchement je me sens absolument
pas à ma place
non mais c'est mon travail mon fils
c'est lui qui a voulu venir hein ben je
suis désolé je suis désolé je suis
désolé vraiment dans les a priori et ça
c'est très grave pas du tout non mais
écoutez-moi je pense que vous allez très
très mal et je pense que vraiment de
souci
je pense que vraiment vous allez mal et
ne me prenez pas de haut je vous demande
les gens dehors oui
pour le clash pour le scandale vous êtes
le benjamin Lady du cul bien sûr bien
sûr j'ai beaucoup de peine pour Léo j'ai
beaucoup de peine pour Léo alors il va
vous répondre non mais ça me regarde pas
parce que oui
vous êtes il a dit
au fil des épisodes au fil au fil des
émissions on voit bien que j'avais une
usage féminine j'ai pas eu horrible
c'est vous qui avez besoin de consulter
vraiment mais nous on va très bien en
fait c'est vous qui montez vous pouvez
sur les réseaux sociaux
avec vos débats juste clairement les
débats à la con c'est TPMP vous avez le
droit non la revanche
Léo même si il me dit qu'il a 17 ans et
qu'il est très content et qu'il trouve
ça très bien ça rapproche pas de
problème même s'il me dit ça et ben par
mettez-moi de penser que je douterai de
sa parole et que j'aurais peur pour lui
et que une maman aujourd'hui qui dit en
gros on met pas les godes là et on met
les fouilles là et ben je trouve que
c'est pas normal mais normalement
pas de sexualité vous savez combien de
parents
sur Internet
d'école
justement alors Léo écoutez moi je doute
de votre bienveillance que j'avais une
animosité qui se reflète sur votre
visage tout simplement
alors Léo léo est là c'est terminé
comment tu te sens toi léo
je me sens bien après c'est sûr que ça
amène à se poser des questions que ça
mène un peu des questions que mes
parents et faire un choix pareil et moi
on en parlait avant et moi on en parle
avant et comme ils m'ont dit si j'aurais
mis un frein à ça bah il l'aurait pas
fait et moi à travers ça eux aussi
voyaient en plus de ça une liberté
d'agir d'être et de pensée parce que
nous on est tous élevé dans une liberté
d'être et de parler en fait on essaie
d'avoir le moins de tabou possible pour
que on ait rien on n'est rien à se
reprocher qu'on puisse parler tout avec
nos parents et moi j'ai des frères et
sœurs et ça je peux le dire ils savent
même pas c'est quoi le sexe donc c'est
sûr ils vont pas aller chercher eux sur
Internet et des vidéos de mes parents
poil d'ailleurs mais moi c'est un peu
triplé de voir mes parents [__] sur
internet donc je vais pas le chercher
c'est compliqué pour lui c'est bon on
n'est pas là pour aussi pour enfoncer
les hauts qui a 17 ans vous êtes très
étriqué dans votre truc faut penser
comme vous c'est des cons tout le monde
pense comme moi maintenant
[Applaudissements]
s'il vous plaît pas alors pas
gilbertez
qu'il a pas de canapé
Léo quand on dit que c'est est-ce que
toi ça te dérange ou pas du tout est-ce
que dans ta vie de tous les jours est-ce
que ça a changé quelque chose dis-nous
la vérité moi dans ma minute dans ma vie
de tous les jours non ça rends changer
dans le sens où dans tous les cas même
si mes parents voilà ils sont orientés
sont d'autres activités
bah eux ils sont ils sont heureux de
faire ce qu'ils font donc moi je suis
content pour eux après forcément je me
suis dit [__] peut-être même faire
chier à l'école peut-être qu'on va se
[__] de ma gueule et tout non non moi
j'ai pas vu j'ai pas constaté je peux
constater ça non parce que après
forcément c'est déjà c'est des plateaux
voilà c'est c'est sécurisé c'est fait en
sorte pour que tout ne fuites pas
partout non plus et dans le pire des cas
tous les jours alors parenthèse pour
l'elix les fuites en fait les
délinquants c'est pas nous nous on est
sur des plateformes cadrées sécurisant
cadré par la on est soumis un régime de
l'URSSAF et on fait des impôts l'hélixe
donc les fuites tous les médias sont
traqués tous les jours les plateformes
et on a embauché quelqu'un donc
récemment justement pour traquer les
fuites sur le web et les plateformes
adjacent parce que avec tous merdier il
a tout ce buzz tous bordel évidemment il
y a des petits malins ils prennent les
contenus ils les achètent ils les
repartent c'est eux les délinquants
c'est pas nous ne mélangeons pas tout en
fait c'est où les vacances
de fuite Léo donc aujourd'hui tu en es
où tu leur dis quoi tu es pas en haut tu
leur dis si c'est si ça va moi mes
parents ils ont décidé de faire ça après
voilà c'était leur choix moi je
respectais leur choix et puis ils m'ont
expliqué pourquoi il voulait faire ça
ils m'ont expliqué ce qui ce qui voulait
en tirer en fait et qu'est-ce qu'il
voulait en tirer bah de comment dire
d'exprimer déjà de comment dire pas de
banaliser ça mais plus de qui est moins
de tabou à propos du sexe vis-à-vis ça
voilà de vulgariser
comme les influences quoi tout
simplement vous êtes des influenceurs
c'est de la mode c'est de la
monétisation de contenu effectivement
mais qui n'est absolument pas interdit
en fait alors
quand Raymond te dit Alexandre tu lui as
dit déjà
parce que c'est beau de faire des vidéos
sur Internet pour pour faire le beau sur
internet mais moi je lui dis juste fais
attention à tes enfants reprends ta
famille en main si tu as une femme qui
part dans tous les sens parce qu'elle
veut de la lumière essaie toi de essaye
toi de reprendre les choses de dire
voilà faut que je fasse attention de pas
me laisser embarquer dans n'importe quoi
les enfants ils ont 3 ans ils ont 6 ans
évidemment qui parlent pas aujourd'hui
évidemment que tu as d'enfant de 3 ans
qui va pas venir par an convocation
c'est pas bien ce que vous faites avec
le canapé ils ont trois ans je pense
après
et je te regarde dans les yeux c'est
beau de faire des trucs sur Instagram
mais
ta famille en main tu dois être l'homme
tu dois être le patriarche fais
attention de pas te faire engrainer par
par ta femme qui est en train de faire
n'importe quoi
[Applaudissements]
non mais on aimerait que Alexandre lui
répondit Alexandre il va parler comme un
homme
il fait des vidéos sur Internet
lui je pense
pour tes enfants Alex non moi j'ai pas
peur franchement on est on sera toujours
là pour eux puis qu'on a on est là pour
rien et le truc c'est que on fait
peut-être on fait ça le soir ça fait
face à la journée
à l'école on fait des sorties on fait on
va dans les bois on vit avec moi en fait
on fait des sorties on n'est pas des
acheter des yaourts des îles flottantes
mais en fait tu laisses pas parler
il respectueux en fait
nos enfants ça n'a rien à voir nos
enfants pourquoi nos enfants nos enfants
on se lève le matin on s'occupe d'eux
voilà stop pourquoi mélanger tous les
enfants avec les contenus non là vous
mélangez tous c'est ça le truc qu'on je
vous entends dire ouais faut leur
enlever les enfants oui il faut
l'enlever
c'est dégueulasse c'est dégueulasse nous
nous enfants on les aime nous on sait
voilà on a fait on a huit enfants si on
a fait 8 enfants c'est pas pour les
laisser de côté de la merde on s'occupe
de nos enfants tu vois on s'occupe de
nos enfants tu vois faut arrêter de
juger vous juger en fait vous savez pas
ce que vous jugez et moi je trouve ça
pas normal que j'ai des gens comme ça
juste toi parce que on fait voilà des
contenus pour adultes le soir dans une
plateforme privée c'est privé si
quelqu'un voilà sur Youtube et tout ça
veut dire que c'est des délinquants
comme disait qu'ils ont fait ça veut
dire qu'il y a du trafic là dedans
c'est-à-dire que les gens gagnent de
l'argent sur nous on y peut rien nous on
fait de notre contenu c'est tout les
victimes
c'est une charge d'utilisation
je trouve que la manière dont mes
collègues
ce soir ouh là là la manière dont mes
collègues jugent et linge cette famille
est indigne honteux et ahurissant merci
parce que là c'est du parti
allez-y allez c'est du parti pris total
même même les paroles sensées du jeune
Léo de 17 ans ne vous font pas peur
les parents de Léo et heureusement pour
Léo mais qu'elle parrainez-vous j'ai
ahurissant
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
je répondrai par l'amour d'une famille
pour ses enfants voilà
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
pas toi alors Léo
la question est-ce que tu es heureux
dans ta vie voilà c'est ça moi je suis
moi ma vie en fait que ça soit des
couilles
ils ont commencé à faire ça ou avant il
a pas changé en fait moi j'ai toujours
été content dans ma vie j'ai des parents
qui sont là pour moi et s'il y a des
gens qui peuvent pas le comprendre et
qui peuvent encore juger bah je les
emmerde et c'est toi alors juste léo je
voulais parler d'un truc qui est
important quand même c'est que ça
rapporte énormément d'argent on a vu que
ça vous a rapporté près de 26 ans
est-ce que votre vie a changé est-ce que
vous avez plus de moi je veux te dire
depuis que je suis gamin que ce soit
pour moi mais moi tu vois à Noël à mes
anniversaires toujours demander les
derniers les dernières consoles les
trucs les plus chers tu vois je les ai
toujours que ça soit avant ou après
c'est pas une question d'argent c'est
pas c'est pas je prends leur parti parce
qu'ils gagnent plus d'argent ou autant
d'argent c'est pas une question d'argent
moi mes parents s'ils sont épanouis dans
leur travail ils sont heureux dans ce
qu'ils font bah tant mais moi ma vie
elle a pas changé et eux ils sont
heureux dans ce qu'il donc je vois pas
le problème alors
le cerveau de certaines personnes quoi
je pense sur Mathieu moi je veux juste
dire un mot quand je sais pas moi j'ai
pas d'enfant quand je sais pas je
demande à ceux qui savent ceux qui
savent c'est psychiatre et
pédopsychiatre alors je vais regarder
sur internet pardon juste l'impact que
ça peut avoir pour des enfants de voir
leurs parents faire l'amour j'entends
bien si un jour
si un jour ça pue pour ceux qui ont 3
ans mais ça fuite visiblement
c'est pas de votre faute mais peu
importe
que ce soit de votre faute ou pas les
gamins l'auront vu et selon les
pédopsychiatres c'est un véritable
traumatisme que de voir ses parents
faire l'amour comme on l'a vu tout à
l'heure pour ceux et cette gamine de 5
ans qui a vu son père se faire battre
pensez trois secondes vraiment si vous
pouvez je ne donne pas de son j'en ai
pas donc je m'en à ceux qui savent
pédopsychiatre pense à 3 secondes à ces
gamins d'autres restes avant
effectivement et combien de gamins
descendent de leur chambre parce que ça
on en voit plein sur les forums de maman
enfin moi j'ai enfin j'étais enceinte
pendant plus de 10 ans donc quand on
oublie que les forums parentaux je les
ai côtoyés fréquentés de près pendant
longtemps et pose-partum etc combien de
parents ce sont voilà je t'emmerde purée
le gamin c'est le veste nul ou vers la
porte
[Applaudissements]
mais c'est encore pire mais personne n'a
vu quoi que ce soit en fait à quelle
heure des enfants ont accès à Internet
mais peu importe
à quel âge a quel âge Alain jouissons
comme les WC
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que je peux vous laisser le
dernier Moscou qu'est-ce que vous auriez
à dire à à Raymond et pourquoi toujours
[Rires]
moi j'aimerais bien
donc c'est vrai que c'est compliqué à
faire
l'objectifs
on va faire du yoga
Raymond le petit cochon
un code promo
[Applaudissements]
écoute-moi déjà mon truc les gens que
j'aime pas je vais pas les voir sur
internet qu'est-ce que tu fous sur mon
story qu'est-ce que tu fous sur nos
story
je regarde pas
sa vie sur nos story seulement de la fin
Léo
il sait tout ce qui se passe
non c'est
[Musique]
[Rires]
après voilà de mon point de vue même si
mes parents voient là ils ont changé
d'activité ils sont comme ils sont ils
resteront comme ils sont moi ils m'ont
ils m'ont élevé ils sont ils sont
toujours c'est toujours mes parents même
s'ils font ça maintenant c'est toujours
mes paroles je sais qui ils sont
toujours là pour leur gosse quoi donc
même si un jour il y a des problèmes
avec les gamins que ça soit à l'école
que ça soit sur Internet ou quoi et des
mesures qui seront prises et qui ils
feront quelque chose pour ça voilà même
s'ils ont décidé de faire ça forcément
il y a des enjeux forcément ça mène à se
poser des questions et je pense pas que
une telle vague de haine en fait une
telle vague de les gens se mettent à
notre place en fait ils parlent ils
parlent pour nous sans savoir qu'est-ce
qu'on vit en fait et ça je trouve ça un
peu un peu dégueulasse